bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono pochi j
oggi andiamo avanti contro mai ping
l'ennesima puntata che non mi ricordo
neanche che numero è ho voluto fare draw
my thing oggi perché da domani inizia se
tutto va bene una serie nuova domenica
sorpresone sabato video speciale quindi
oggi sono andato sul tranquillo
dell'ultimo giorno in cui vado su
tranquillo che ott e il bello sarebbe
mongolfiera facciamo quella dobbiamo
disegnare una mongolfiera fantastico
allora vediamo se riesco a fare qualcosa
di decente
vabbè comunque non lo so non importa
questa è una mongolfiera vai vai bordate
che disegno madonna è fantastico non si
può non indovinare che questa è una
mongolfiera perfetto l'avete azzeccato
ce l'ho fatta novi sentirò un completo
idiota
vi ricordo che se volete partecipare
ovviamente sto giocando con voi in
questo momento basta mettere mi piace
alla pagina di facebook e ogni tanto
quando mi gira di registrare dr meeting
lo scrivo sulla pagina di facebook i
primi che entrano riescono appunto a
partecipare allora siamo partiti sono
secondo questo cos'è è un mouse è un
mouse è che culo che cura assurdo come
cazzo mi è venuto in mente mouse c'è ma
quello è tutto meno che un mouse sono
primo 5 punti va iniziamo da dio
raga voglio vincerle tutte tutte quante
questa puntata voglio inaugurare no
microfono vincendo tutto allora questa
dai dai che vendo vino 4 light light
white light o non light che cazzo è la
l'ump lampo no sono sempre primo se ce
la posso fare me lo sento che posso
me lo sento che ce la posso fare cos'è
domino domino domino madonna che culo
domino se ce la posso fare
mi sto avvicinando al traguardo
incredibile 9 punti se non ce n'è per
nessuno
le vinco tutto questo ovviamente raga la
prima partita è sempre per riscaldamento
diciamo non lo so cos'è sta roba batte
no kat
no sono sempre primo cos'è sta roba cosa
mi rappresenta cos'è a labbra lips basta
ancora
troppo tardi maledizione ok sono sempre
qui allora sono sempre primo devo
riuscire a indovinare assolutamente
questa perché se no vado a pari merito
maledizione dove indovinarlo
assolutamente ok ok ok non so che cos'è
cos'è aiuto è una è cos'è sta roba è un
pesce spada è un codice pesce spada
cazzo pesce spada [ __ ] il
contrario swordfish swordfish ce l'ho
fatta
che culo ho vinto per un punto ce l'ho
fatta incredibile raga la prima partita
l'ho vinta io non ci posso credere
iniziamo benissimo direi che da ora
possiamo iniziare seriamente allora la
parola è medaglia d'oro taco tacco
facciamo tacco
ok non mi ricordo cosa è un ragazzo
aspettateci di memoria mirenda di
geniali tipo no dogs infatti è così bene
sprovveduto andare a vedere che cos'era
un tacco pensate che cazzo di yacht a
chi me l'ha fatto fare di fare sta cosa
vabbè proviamo a farlo lo stand non mi
ricordo come che cazzo devo disegnarci
proprio ok
ebbene raga preparatevi per il tacco più
gustoso del mondo diventerò il cuoco
migliore del mondo a far sta roba
ok questo è un tacco vai fa vj
fantastico
l'insalata ci voleva mettere anche la
maionese maledizione non ce l'ho fatta
però c'è uno che la indovinato non so
come non me lo chiedete perché quello a
tutto meno che un tacco ma va bene così
perfetto ragazzone al secondo posto il
primo mi sta massacrando perché ne ha 6
ma posso vincerla
allora possiamo questa quale indovino
senza sapere neanche la parola allora
banana a caso le lettere cerano no è
veramente non ne mancava uno ma non
importa da questo è un è un è un una
patata rossa che cos'è sta roba
me lo spieghi che cazzo è sta roba come
fai a disegnare con il bianco sul bianco
fammi capire è una bistecca è una beast
come si dice bis bis bistecca stack
state no stea come cazzo lo scritto se
ce l'ho fatta l'ho preso
ti sto dietro ma che non andò vini fa
che volendo vini fa che non land ovini
c'ero ho fatto a 5 punti il primo a sei
ti riprendo ce la posso fare la caccia
la posso fare
cos'è è una è un horse and bear no
ma com'è il caso è possibile non aveva
neanche fatto la testa l'avevate già
indovinato
e va beh non questo che cazzo mi
rappresenta questo dovrebbe essere un
orso c'è ma che cazzo
rendetevi conto della qualità dei
disegni raga ma neanche picasso cos'è oh
mio dio quanta roba c'è ke kazzo estero
che non lo so è un dildo un po grosso è
una è un birillo così ce pirillo
birillo pin che a bowling pin bob
bowling pin
beh se ce l'ho fatta
nove punti 11 ragazzo la posso fare non
ci ha indovinato solo io
raga siamo in testa allora io 9 punti un
altro ne ha due un altro una 31 a 32
l'altro ne ha 11 che non so come cazzo
far averne così tanti l'altro neo
nell'ultimo 0 raga devo riuscire
indovinare questa stratosferica che
cazzo scritto garden no
e golf no non è golf sanna tramonto come
si dice tramonto tramonto sunset science
at sunset no sense e sunset ma come
cazzo lo indovinata 8 secondi dai a pari
merito 12 punti non ci credo ok
raga l'ultima sono a pari merito 12
punti ho rimontato 6 indovino questo ho
vinto ce la posso fare
sun h dog wolf aiuto wolf cazzo gray
cos'è cos'è sta roba cos'è sta roba
una padella una padella come si dice
padella
padella padella padella c'è ancora
attacco padella pan non è panna
maledizione è un disco disco disco se ho
vinto 9 rimontato 13 punti ho vinto io
l'ho fatta per primo non rompete questa
no non ti accetto l'amicizia perché ha
imparato avete visto tutti che l'ho
scritta per primo io allora non ce n'è
ok ragazzi son andiamo con la prossima
dress gorilla gorilla lo so fare da dio
allora iniziamo fatemi pensa che cazzo
allora è bene facciamo una roba del
genio dio che cosa fantastica
ecco cosa sto facendo
devo mio dio non c'è fantasia allora mi
viene da disegnare una roba enorme però
mi sembra più un palestrato che un
gorilla
questo è un gorilla fantastico guardate
che cazzo
sto disegnando cos'è sta roba fanta
guardate che roba
guardate che questo è un gorilla
rendetevi conto delle qualità dei miei
disegni
cos'è sta roba
cosa che questo è un gorilla
cr sembra che mario palestrato c'è ma
che cazzo il disegno più epico di sempre
vabbè gr grazie grazie a tutti
sì lo so è un gorilla questo è un
gorillone hai mai visto un gorilla tu
credi che i gorilla siano come pensi tu
ma in realtà sono così perché non è mai
visti disegnati da fa vj se mi metto il
cappello da michael jackson secondo me
indovino di più è ok perfetto come non
detto il cappello porta sfiga la [ __ ]
che cos'è cosa mi rappresenta
è una spa spa da combattimento che cos'è
star war mio zio
questa è una guerra allora raga io non
ho mai visto una guerra più reale di
questa neanche 300 era così
comunque va beh facciamo finta di niente
io non ho visto nulla sto a 0 raga sto a
0 fan sun sun facile non è san potato
limone lila lemon nova cazzo sono
l'unico non aveva indovinato ma che sono
a 0ra gah sono a zero
sono l'unico deficiente a 0 ma cazzo
cos'è cos'è sta roba accendino accendino
come si ci accendino accendino accendino
mico accendino
l'ater l'ater l'ater l'ater l'ater
l'ater shampoo
[Musica]
che cazzo scritto io l'ater cioè non c'è
mi sono sbattuto per scriverle per la
sbagliata vabbè se una ragazza ente non
c'è questo che cos'è dove indovinarla
cos'è il braccio non è braccio cos'è sta
roba è una stretta di mano
presicce stretta stretta di mano and
shake and sheikh
c'è un punto ce l'ho fatta se sono a 1
incredibile mi sento veramente
soddisfatto raga incredibile non ti
accetto perché sono incazzato
dimenticate l'asta partita fate finta di
niente mummia 3 occhiali 3 occhiali 3d
occhiali 3d assolutamente allora vediamo
se riesco a fare un qualcosa di decente
ok raga questi li faccio veramente se
potessi di fare in 3d davvero così lo
vedete proprio dal video che in 3d però
questi riso fare li so fare
cos'è sta roba ok dove deve ancora
arrivare a pezzo forte state tranquilli
ok ok fantastico manca il pezzo forte
mai un agendo vi nato fantastico manca
l'altro manca l'altro blue sea perfetto
vai ce la posso fare da illuminate s
cos'è sta roba mi sembrano più due
tartarughe una col dorso rosso una col
dorso blu ma vanno benissimo lo stesso
ma io c'ho ancora al tacco ma cazzo ma
ammirato e che figo non l'ho fatto così
io prima uguale vabbè cos'è sta roba è
una macchina fotografica l'ora dollar
dollar dollar cioè è un po in ritardo ma
mi accontento va benissimo
ok allora sono ultimo praticamente non
lo so vabbè sono tra gli ultimi comunque
va beh devo ricercare indovinare subito
ragazzi amo all'ultima devo cercare di
indovinare per primo ma tanto nomico lo
stesso vabbè ci ho provato maledizione
non posso vincere sempre
l'altra ne devo far vincere anche quelli
che sono un po più scarsi no ok non ci
crede nessuno
cos'è sta roba è una telecamera
telecamera camera
sì però a spec di telecamera come via
videocamera video chat video camera ok
non è se c'è cu lo era ma vi la camera
non si iscrive tutto attaccato i mi
ricordavo così sono arrivato almeno
secondo no veramente se un terzo ma non
gli porta
pavia j ok fantastico grazie mille sono
arrivato praticamente se non rispondeva
arrivavo più avanti ma non importa va
bene ok raga direi di fare l'ultima
speriamo di riuscire a vincere almeno
questa sono pronto marshmallow grazie
per avermi ricordato il fatto che devo
fare la sfida dei chabib anni ok
perfetto io ho finito poi fate voi
proviamo a farlo sullo stecco che ok
avete in sei veramente un genio perché
non so come è fatta indovinarla non me
lo spiego però va bene così
c'è adesso mi spiegate come ha fatto a
indovinare dinamite dinamite dynamite e
non è quella explosiva neanche cioè
dynamite non andava bene scusa come
cazzo l'ho scritto io
c'è a cola i normale porca [ __ ]
maledizione
mi sono dimenticato devo scriverlo in
inglese ovviamente georges perché
perfetto vice sono arrivato ultimo ma
non importa va bene così quanto siamo
messi a punteggio terzo
ok rispetto a tutti gli altri una merda
fantastico ok io non voglio aggiungere
commenti ma proprio zero mano and farm
clock come si dice orologio che cazzo
come cazzo braccia braccialetto nova che
palle ma dai cazzo ma [ __ ] sto
gioco raga mi odi aspetta l'ultimo
secondo aspetta l'ultimo secondo perché
io sbagli gioco e bastardo ce l'ha con
me maledizione che cos'è un quadrato
quadra cube cube quadrato è che ne so io
mio dio ma non riesco indovinarle
neanche una
[ __ ] small io ce l'elasticità
mentale di un lombrico che cosa vi devo
dire
vabbè sono arrivato ultimo fantastico
sono partito da dio e ho concluso di
merda comunque raga vi dico che questo è
l'ultimo video tranquillo diciamo della
settimana quindi da domani
aspettatevi se tutto va bene la nuova
serie e poi ovviamente video speciale
sabato e domenica anche lì se riesco una
sorpresa ci sta se volete partecipare
alla prossima puntata di dro my thing
basta mettere mi piace alla pagina di
facebook che trovate nella descrizione e
quando vi gira di registrarlo scrivo ii
e quelli che partecipano gli eventi
hanno la possibilità di partecipare c'è
di apparire nel video e di giocare con
me comunque la trovate nella descrizione
come al solito se vi dove è piaciuto
lasciato un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook appunto come in ogni
video trovate nella descrizione se non
siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi noi ci
vediamo in un prossimo video bella
ragazzi